do you all practice the five second rule
raise of hands
yeah i mean i've done like a ten second
rule right um okay martha stewart.com
reports that scientists have actually
tested the five-second rule in a
lab they dropped a piece of bologna well
that's just like that's gross all right
it's like tape yeah right i'm just gonna
pick something
totally taped um and a piece of dry
bread on a surface with uh salmonella on
it and they let it sit for five seconds
30 seconds and then a full minute and
the results are in
regardless of how long it sat there the
food was
very definitely contaminated oh man
even after just five seconds that
baloney was salmonella city
oh
god
well i mean oh man
i feel like there are two types of five
second rules in the world there's like
five second rule around people and
you're like no i'm not gonna
and then there's the five second rule at
home where you're like that's been there
for like i don't know a few minutes i
actually one time just found a jelly
bean
and i ate it i don't know
you know what do you do do you remember
when like rachel and joey are like
eating the cake in their hallway like
off the floor does anyone remember that
i do what about miranda on sex the city
eating the cake out of the garbage can
she had to pour like soap on it i've
done that i've done it done it i i've
been like enough
totally um well so is this going to skew
you will you no longer count the flavor
how often is there a patch of salmonella
around
well do you really want to know the
answer well yeah all right up next hey
are you ready to try the latest tick
tock trend you guys always well allure
reports the newest makeup hack is called
the tape contour people are using clear
tape you know just like scotch tape on
you you have on your desk as a guiding
tool for applying their makeup and we
have some right here you want to try it
i'll show you how it works she's doing
it right there you take a big piece of
tape like this
and you just open your mouth like this
uh-huh
uh uh-huh yeah
oh you're good good i
i heard i'm gonna get caught on my baby
hairs
it might
yeah okay i
right
oh yeah look
oh
can you see it he's here
and then
and then you blend hi
and then
you're extra gorgeous hi
what do you think
i guess i could take this off now
kind of like it you know what i like to
do is this one where you take your like
[Laughter]
oh look and i don't even have a line
you're good
and then i would do my eyelids too like
this
pretty good
i am freaking out i love this it really
worked it does work look at me
before we go if you love a good podcast
because we all do check out ours the
drew barrymore show podcast because
we're podcasting wherever everybody
podcasts we're there
[Music]
you